and las vegas now host mercedes martinez
as you see is on your screen
in her studio helping us rise and shine
with some positive stories
live from the mix 941 studios mercedes
it's good to see you this morning how
you doing
good to see you john welcome back from
vacation we missed you and yes i've got
a real
tear jerker of a story for you today so
i hope you have some tissues nearby
fair warning a woman had a big surprise
for her sister-in-law's father for the
past year
she has been undergoing testing and is
now letting him know
that she has been approved to be his
kidney donor
the moment he found out was caught on
camera take a look
[Music]
[Music]
as you can see he was absolutely
overwhelmed with emotion and for good
reason
the woman's daughter recorded the video
and said
she is absolutely amazed at how
thoughtful her mom is
this video was just posted on tick tock
two days ago
and it already has more than two million
likes
john yeah mercedes should have about two
million more i mean
when you talk about those donations
that's you know that's life and death
stuff right there that is important uh
that is so
vital and uh one can only imagine the
surprise when you see uh
your uh your sister-in-law i guess it
would be to make that announcement and
do it in that way is just beautiful
stuff
it really is and and john just to switch
gears a little bit i wanted to
check in with you and see since i've
been away from you for a week i feel
like we've kind of
lost our connection are you a fan of
kiss by
chance oh uh i i don't i'm all right
with kiss i can live with that yeah
i i saw your little encounter with that
with mr simmons
yes well that full interview is going to
be airing this afternoon on las vegas
now we talk about his art we talk about
his residency
and i was wondering i mean can you
perfect the kiss
well my my hands can't do that neither
yeah i better stop that sentence but i
will say
he he called you a work of art he called
you a work of art
you know what i'm i'm willing to put
money on the fact that he calls
everyone a work of art i don't think it
was special to me oh come on now
mercedes thank you very much that was a
rise and shine right there we'll
see you on las vegas now later today
have a good rest of the show this
morning
you are a work of art john you are a
work of art have a good day
thanks mercedes